That's how you doing buddy?
Yes.
What's up? You always in working now?
Sound up.
I think so young man.
When I say young man, how old are you if
you don't mind me asking?
I tell them a thing. Hold on a second.
Okay, can you hear me?
Yeah, I can hear you. Can you hear me?
Great, I can hear you. Perfect. Only
problem
I can hear
No, you're good now.
Great.
How old are you young man?
I'm good, thank you.
>> You go to Speakers' Corner often? Yes.
I didn't know that. Ah, hello.
So what when you go to Speakers' Corner,
who do you engage?
I haven't been for about a year and a
half, but I used to talk to all sorts of
people, Muslims, Christians, atheists,
all sorts.
Okay, so when you debated Muslims, what
topic?
What do you use?
Usually whether Muhammad's in the Torah.
That's good. You know, that kind of
stuff.
So when they bring up Song of Solomon
5:16, Muhammadin I laugh in their face.
Good man.
At least you're an equal opportunist
hater.
I don't hate. No, sorry man. I say that
kind way. It's you know, I was Yeah,
we all love to hate and hate to love. So
but I mean you're you're not one of
those that bends over backwards to
appease Muslims because sadly there are
some rabbis that do that. You're not one
of those. I'm aware. I'm aware.
Good man. I like this guy really cuz I I
just met him the first time with
Avery. I didn't know much about him. So
I didn't know how his approach, but it
turns out that he's been at Speakers'
Corner.
And so he likes to engage. And one thing
I admired a lot about you, the one thing
I saw, when you saw statements, you
corrected yourself immediately. I like
that.
When you went and checked, he goes, "Oh
yeah, yeah. I saw in the commentary,
you're right." So that I like. That
means it's more
not of an ego fest where you got to win.
Because if you see a fact, you
acknowledge it.
I like that, man. A lot of people just
want to argue even if they get a source
that's in front of their face. I
appreciate that. May God be glorified.
When I talked to you last time, I said,
"Contact Avery, we can discuss." But
Avery got married this Monday. He signed
his life away.
So, he won't be around for maybe 2
weeks. So, I said, "If I could maybe
bring you on sooner
and talk about
the Messiah in the Hebrew scriptures."
Cuz number one, guys, remember, they
don't call it Old Testament. It's
Tanakh. Just want people who don't know
the language of the rabbis. Tanakh.
And because he's an Orthodox Jew,
when we use Hebrew names for God, he
will not pronounce them
lest he takes God's name in vain. So, he
will say Elohim,
right? Or he'll say Hashem.
So, he will not pronounce the name. Just
understand this. This is his tradition.
This is what he's taught. In order to
make sure he doesn't profane the name of
God, he'll say Elohim
or Hashem. Keep that in mind. Correct.
Yeah, I just want the people to know.
So, I told you I would be interested in
talking to you about Messiah in the
Hebrew scriptures and in the Talmud
because you are aware
there's
certain rabbis that say that in Judaism,
there is no concept of a dying rising
Messiah. But you know that's not true,
right?
Um well, it depends what you're talking
about. If you're talking about uh
Messiah ben Yosef, then there you have a
dying person who is a Messiah. Or if
you're talking about Messiah ben David,
then you're talking about someone who
certainly didn't certainly isn't
supposed to die and therefore doesn't
rise.
Okay. Um with Messiah ben Yosef, um when
we talk about rising after he's been
killed, that's talking about in the
general um revival of the dead um it's
so amongst everyone else. Although he's
supposed to be one of the first The war
of Gog and Magog, right? Yeah.
And that happens because of Mashiach ben
David
asked for his life, correct? Yes. Okay.
So, but
note what I said. I go there are rabbis
who say that in Judaism there is no
concept of a a dying and rising Messiah,
but you agree that's not true, right?
Um in in the way that I just said. Yes.
So, there is a Messiah
>> that I just said.
a Messiah who dies and rises, right?
Who's killed, right? Right. He I mean he
he he's not he doesn't have to be
killed, right? So, this is also separate
about tradition that the that the that
that Mashiach ben Yosef doesn't have to
be killed is only if we're not
deserving, then this war will happen and
he'll be killed. If we are deserving, um
then then then the war will happen and
he'll be killed. And then he's brought
back in the in the general reviving of
the dead.
Um but when we talk about the Messiah,
we're not
we never really talk about him as the
Messiah. When we talk about the Messiah,
we're talking about Mashiach ben David,
the Davidic king. Yep. We'll get there.
We'll get there whether this concept
that separated Messiah son of David from
Messiah son of Joseph evolved. But what
I want to people to see is
in Judaism
what you just articulated, I want people
to see this,
is that though you have prophecies
stated in scripture. I wanted you to
hear what he said.
These prophecies can be changed because
they're not written in stone. Because
notice he says if one unworthy, it will
happen. So, that means Zechariah 12:10
is conditional. It won't happen, right?
Necessarily?
Um any any negative prophecy like for
example when Jonah comes to the people
of Nineveh and says you're going to die.
Um any conditional
um prophecy which isn't which is
negative, can be annulled if people are
worthy, if people are righteous, if
people repent.
Um
yeah.
So, this they shall look to me and mourn
over him whom they pierced
as a man mourns over his only son. And
our sages expand this tractate Sukkah
52A as referring to the Messiah son of
Joseph who was slain.
So, this is Rashi. So, Zechariah 12:10
This is contingent. This is clearly
contingent because um because as it's
clear as it's clarified by by the rabbis
in various places in the Medrash,
um the whole war that's described here
and the um and the whole
um
the whole episode of Mashiach ben Yosef
being killed doesn't have to happen. It
It's not something which has to happen.
It's something that it's a it it's it's
hanging over our heads. If you don't do
as you're told, then this is what's
going to end up happening before the
ultimate redemption. It's going to be a
a very difficult time.
That's exactly why I to color why I
asked the question cuz I wanted people
to see that even the rabbis hold a form
of open theism.
The future is not fixed, it's settled
and not settled and fixed.
And this is only one expression of the
Hebrew scriptures because
>> Christians Yes.
>> I'm curious. Do
Do Christians not believe that because
there is Jonah, after all?
Say it again.
Do Christians not believe that because
there is Jonah,
after all? No, we have We don't No,
Christians believe that there are
conditions that if they're not met, it
won't happen, but
that those conditions, there has to be
strong reasons why
we assume that this prophecy may have
conditions
attached to it, so it won't be fulfilled
as stated.
In other words, we don't just
decide, oh, well, this is a prophecy
that has certain conditions that have to
be met. And if those predictions are
met, then it's conditional. We can't
just do that cuz then we can argue
ourselves out of every
paradox.
But if there's a negative prophecy and
no conditions attached, then that
negative prophecy will definitely come
to pass.
But that's not what we find with Jonah
because in Jonah chapter 1
>> an isolated case.
I I I
So, that's not how we interpret it. The
way we interpret Jonah is Hold on a
second. Is that it is that
Jonah simply says in verse 2, "Go So,
God says to Jonah in verse 2 in chapter
1, 'Go at once to Nineveh, that great
city, and proclaim judgment upon it, for
their wickedness has come before me.'"
Right?
No. Now, he doesn't say
um that uh that Oh, if you're if you um
if you repent,
um it's going to be fine. No, it it
doesn't stop there.
I don't mean to cut you off, but this is
why I'm saying no because go to chapter
4, it's already stated there a
condition. No, you're not right. Uh I
know these arguments.
Josh, I'm going to show you no, you're
not right. Why? Because
Why did Jonah number one Why did Jonah
run away? I'm going to show you you're
misreading Jonah. I just let you speak
cuz I don't want to be accused of
cutting you off. Sure. Because this is
why I cut people off so we don't go on
tangents, but I let you speak
to let you know when I cut you off, it's
not because I'm trying to be rude, it's
because I don't want to go off our
drift. Number one, you're wrong about
Jonah. It actually proves my point.
Here's two reasons.
If Jonah thought
that this was an unconditional threat of
judgment, why did he flee?
I mean, in other words, if according to
you, when God said he'll destroy
Nineveh, and that destruction of Nineveh
is not
stated that it's unconditional. That's
your argument. It wasn't There was no
condition stated that unless they they
But see,
he said you'll be destroyed 40 days, but
he didn't destroy them. So, every
negative prophecy has built in it a
condition. No, because the context of
Jonah shows that already
God had already demonstrated that the
negative
prophecy
would not come to pass
if they repented. How do we know? Number
one, why did Jonah flee?
Jonah fled because he didn't want um he
he he he he he he he he he he he didn't
he didn't want it to be that people will
look at at the Jews who have been told
so many times about
about bad things that are going to
happen to them and haven't and haven't
changed direction and haven't repented.
Um if the people of Nineveh repent, then
um then then then then then this
negative thing is going to be averted.
That's going to show badly on the Jews.
So, you just made my case. He doesn't
say in the prophecy though Yes, he does.
that the patch. Yes, Jonah 4. He just
says it. And In Jonah chapter 4, he um
it says, "Arise, go to Nineveh, the
great city, and proclaim upon it the
proclamation that I speak to you."
Um and so and then in verse 4 it says
Jonah 3 is right there. It's right in
front of you. It's right in front of
you.
Yeah, I'm reading it. And Jonah arose
and went to Nineveh according to the
word of the Lord. And Nineveh was an
exceedingly great city. So, this is
You're not reading chapter 4.
I'm reading chapter 3. Sorry. Yeah, it's
right there. It's right there. It's on
the screen. Read it.
Oh, it's on the screen. Hold on.
Um
Now, this people of Nineveh exceedingly
he was grieved and he prayed to the Lord
and said, "Please, oh Lord, was this not
my contention while I was still on my
land? For this reason I hastened to flee
to Tarshish, for I know that you are a
gracious and merciful God, slow to anger
with much kindness and relenting of
evil.
And now, oh Lord, take now my soul from
me, for my death is better than my
life." Right? So, we see that It's right
there.
that Jo- that Jonah knows that when God
says a negative prophecy, even though he
doesn't attach onto it a specific
condition, like what we saw in Jeremiah
18, even though that's the case, Jonah
is is aware that that that if people
repent, then God will be merciful, so
it's out of anger and not kindness, and
will relent of the evil. Okay. Now,
Josh,
you made the same point over and over
again. What I was trying to show you is
your misreading of Jonah. That's all I'm
trying to show you.
You did not read Jonah carefully. You
kept using Jonah, and I told you, "No,
Jonah itself shows that God's threat of
destruction wasn't unconditional because
we see it from chapter 1 and 4
that there there is the condition
implied in chapter 1 and 2 when Jonah
fled, and then explicitly stated in
chapter 4.
But when God said he's going to destroy
the Babylonians in 70 years, you mean
that was conditional?
Of course. If the Babylonians had been
righteous, if they had been
if they had repented, then
they would have been they would have
been saved. Then how would you return to
the land?
Sorry?
Then how would you return to the land?
Well, if they'd have been righteous,
they would have returned us to the land.
Okay. So, then the 70 years prophecy,
you're saying when it says 70 years to
make up for all the Sabbath years that
Israel failed to observe.
So, they would have to be in captivity
70 years. You're saying that's also
conditional?
Negative things
So, the negative parts of that are
conditional, and the positive parts are
not.
Mhm. So, okay. Anyway, so I just wanted
everyone to see
I just wanted to you to make your case
that you are take it for granted
that the negative prophecies are
conditional, but when it's a positive
assertion, there are no conditions
unless it's stated. Whereas Jeremiah 18
says, "No, both negative and positive
prophecies have conditions attached,
whether stated explicitly or
implicitly." But anyway, that's neither
here nor there.